I feel like we should watch The Tick
Tock oh oh did we get the chocolate
buttholes it's right here
I think right
yeah dude so these are edible anus
so these are the ones that we were
joking that what a transition
the chocolate buttholes yet right here
oh yeah they're right here that's
actually part we're adding that to
noelle's Cafe
we're gonna have the chocolate anus uh
printing machine so yeah no you there's
two options you can you can get pre-made
edible anuses that are casts of yours
but then you can also it's a mobile
casting
solution so if you want to cast your own
anus
that's what you're going to offer to
people yeah you can cast your own
yeah this one let me let me get that
thing up look at the wrinkles
it's it
oh bro we need a macro shot on these we
do
let me just walk right up to the lens
with this
you got that yeah
oh
I don't think you're supposed to eat it
like that I think you're supposed to eat
like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
go ahead go ahead
that's it's a it's a chocolate all right
you guys are sick
you can feel the wrinkles
that is kind of like a you know this is
a cast of someone's ass
give it a kiss
[Laughter]
whoa that's how you're supposed to eat
is this really how big an anus is
like a [__] kid's anus okay
whoa dude that's a but your butthole's
bigger than that I don't know I don't
know how big's your [__] I I'm not
I'm that's a normal sized [__] I'm
just trying to think like I won't I've
only
I don't know why are you thinking about
kids [__]
I'm just saying like in terms of size I
don't know how big a kid's anus
it is kind of weird to think about poop
coming out of that that's what I mean is
like you've taken a [__]
that would like hemorrhoid that it kind
of tastes like poop a little bit
no I guess yeah yeah I know that that's
yeah yeah if I just admit yeah yeah
right yeah I don't know why in the Box
they look smaller
I also just thought it'd be funny to say
ew is this a kid we should
we should cast our own then we know for
sure the size of them what I know that's
what it is cast your but here let's
let's order the instructions put your
ankles by your head oh my god dude this
stocks and anus lots of fun for you and
a friend
that's me and you yeah bro I like how it
looks like um like a like a a like a
pitch deck yeah yeah what's step one
okay we got a list of materials here
step one have fun oh items you will need
water measuring jug and open-minded
friend
all right copy a Spare Bowl for mixing
materials a small amount of Vaseline to
help prevent hairs getting caught in the
alginate
of course
and a couple of small coins or chewing
gum for inserting inside the anus
sorry I killed your bit yeah what the
[__] I thought you were reading I
thought you were actually reading
oh my god oh that's yeah that's
that's just putting silly putty in your
ass okay so they make them I'm sorry man
can we just show off this
Oh that's oh wow oh that's [__]
dude that's some you have to censor this
but that's a full-on I was like I wonder
if there's instructions on how to
actually apply it and it is it's that
guy from the front and the other guy and
the other guy is legs over his ankles by
head the open mind is open-minded friend
is like applying the putty to his
[__]
I'll do
[Laughter]
your chair is right there coating will
do that would be the most insane Cody
Noelle do
so bro when you look at these materials
right they have like the clay and all
this [__] and then they have these like
wooden doctor things and that's just for
me to hold your tongue down while I
while I put buddy in your ass
oh bro look at his nutsack
naked dude wait ow
you just kicked yourself in the head
it's these damn glasses I didn't see it
coming
ow I'm gonna have like a [__]
swollen nose from that yeah dude oh man
he's got the clay like bare-handed
and he just smacks it on
that's so crazy just making like a like
a mud pie in your hand and you're like
okay buddy but once you have a cast of
your ass I mean the world kind of your
oyster yeah it is yeah there's a lot of
things you could yeah you're the World's
oyster the oyster right there you could
make oysters yeah
[Laughter]
a little crazy to serve that it's just a
like a Super Bowl party
oh I got some homemade chocolate here
too oh that's what the [__]
bruh what what is this man what are
these oh slow oh it's my [__]
no do you even tell them this one I call
a man's flower
foreign
who's gonna who's gonna do it
who's gonna do it yeah the problem is
like
the bit's not finished unless one of us
actually does that ship so this is
that's honestly that's funny Ryan that's
fair get on your back
yeah lie down this one is YouTube we are
the open-minded friends yeah we're the
open-minded friends dude that are gonna
open you up
cast your own anus bruh yeah who's gonna
do it we should cast somebody like we
will but we should cast like you know
yeah just put out a casting call who
would like somebody anus molded yeah
what dude it has to be somebody that's
like oh I don't give a [__] what if we
could convince a famous person
to give us their ass and we we write an
explicit contract that we will not sell
we won't monetize
this will purely be for confectionary
purposes why not monetize it
well
I'm saying like maybe as an exchange the
famous person will be like you can cast
my anus if you don't sell this but then
we'd split the money with them there's
that too but I'm just saying what we
could do like a museum like a Madame
Tussauds and you go to the end and it's
all famous people's [__] yeah it's
our version It's wax [__] yeah all
famous people yeah
waxholes oh and it's just busts of
anuses yeah and then when we debut a new
bust
you can pay
to uh maybe it's like the first 10
people can get a sniff whoa what I just
can't see I'm trying to read the text
but uh here are 10 most popular porn
stars according to Pornhub what does
this Luke what's going on
you wanted some famous [__] so I'm
[__]
right there's feat Finder right this is
anus analog it's not even really close
to link to that though it's just he just
pulled up a list of the 10 best porn
stars I was trying to think of
open-minded celebrities
[Laughter]